so far we've been dealing with one way
of thinking about probability and that
was the probability of of a occurring is
the number of events that satisfy a
number of events that satisfy a satisfy
a overall of the equally likely events
number of equally likely events oh and
this is all of the equally likely all of
the equally likely events and so in the
case of a fair coin the probability of
heads well it's a fair coin so there's
two equally likely events and we're
saying one of them satisfies being heads
so there's a 1/2 chance of that you
having a heads the same thing for tails
if you took a if you took a die and you
said the probability of getting an even
number when you roll the die well
there's six equally likely events and
there's three even numbers you could get
you could get two of four or six so
there's three even numbers so once again
you have a 1/2 chance of that happening
and this is a really good model where
you have equally likely events happening
now I'm going to change things up a
little bit so I'm going to draw a line
here because this was just one way if
they came up probability now we're going
to introduce another one that's more
helpful when we can't think about
equally likely events and in particular
I'm going to set up an unfair coin so
this right over here is going to be my
unfair coin so that is my coin well I
could draw the coin so it's a gold coin
this time it is unfair one side of that
coin is a little heavier than the other
so even though it's meant to look fair
so it still has that picture of I know
some president or something on on one
side of it so this is the head side this
is heads and then obviously on the back
you have you have tails but as I
mentioned this is an unfair coin and now
I'm going to make an interesting
statement about this unfair coin and one
that really doesn't fit into the mold
that I set up over here and this
interesting statement is that we have
more than a 50/50 chance of getting
heads or more than a 50% chance or more
than a 1/2 chance
getting heads I'm going to say that the
probability of getting heads for this
coin right over here is 60% or another
way to say it it's 0.6 or another way to
say it it is 6 out of 10 or another way
to say it
it is 3/5 and this might make intuitive
sense to you and hopefully it does a
little bit but I want you to realize
that this is fundamentally different
than what we were saying before because
now we can't say that there are two
equally likely events there are two
possible events you can either get heads
or tails we're not assuming that the
coin won't fall on its edge that that's
impossible
so you're either going to get heads and
heads or tails but we can never we but
they're not equally likely anymore so we
really can't do this kind of counting
the number of events satisfy something
over all of the possible events in this
situation in order to visualize the
probability we have to kind of take
what's kind of called a frequentist
approach or think about it in terms of
frequency pomp probability and the way
to conceptualize a 60% chance of getting
heads is to think if we had a super
large number of trials if we were to
just flip this coin this is saying that
if we were to flip this coin a gazillion
times we would expect that 60% of those
would come up heads it's unclear how I
determined that this is 60% maybe I ran
a computer simulation maybe I know
exactly all of the physics of this and I
can completely model how it's going to
fall every time or maybe it's it's I've
actually just run a ton of trials I
flipped the coin a million times and I
said wow 60% of those 600,000 of those
came up heads and then we can make a
similar statement about tails so if the
probability of heads is 60% the
probability of tails well there's only
two possibilities heads or tails so if I
say the probability of heads or tails
it's going to be equal to one because
you're going to get one of those two
things you have a hundred percent chance
of getting a heads or a tails and these
are mutually exclusive events you can't
have both of them so this is going to be
the probability of tails is going to be
100 percent 100 percent minus the
probability of getting heads and this of
course is 60 percent so it's 100 percent
minus 60 percent or 40
percent or as a decimal 0.4 or as a
fraction for tensor as a simplified
fraction 2 over fifths so once again
this probability is saying one thing we
can't say that we can't say equally
likely events we could say that if we're
going to do a gazillion of these we
would expect as we get more and more and
more trials more and more flips 40% of
those would be heads now with that out
of the way let's actually do some
problems with this so let's think about
the probability of getting heads on our
first flip and heads on our second flip
so once again these are independent
events the coin has no memory regardless
of what I got on the first flip I have
an equal chance of getting heads on the
second flip it doesn't matter if I got
heads or tails on the first so this is
the probability of heads on the first
flip times the probability of heads on
the second flip and we already know
probability of heads and on any flip is
going to be 60 percent or another way to
say it I'll write it as a decimal makes
the math a little bit easier 0.6 0.6 and
we can just multiply I'll do it right
over here so this is 0.6 times 0.6 now
it's always good to do a reality check
if I'm take this is one one way to think
about it is I'm taking six tenths of six
tenths so it should be a little bit more
than half of 6/10 so probably a little
bit more than three tenths and then the
and we've explained this in detail where
we talked about multiplying decimals but
we essentially just multiplied the
numbers not thinking about the decimals
at first 6 times 6 is 36 and then you
count the number of digits we have to
the right of the decimal we have one two
to the right of the decimal so we're
going to have two to the right of the
decimal in our answer so it is 0.36 and
that makes sense we're taking 60% of 0.6
we're taking 0.6 0.6 a little bit more
than half of 0.6 and once again it's a
little bit more than 0.3 so this also
makes sense
so it's 0.36 or another way to think
about it is there's a 36% probability
that we get two heads in a row given
this unfair coin remember if it was a
fair coin it would be 1/2 times 1/2
which is 1/4 which is 25% and it makes
sense that this is more than that now
let's think about a slightly more
complicated example
let's say the probability and now let's
let's say the probability of getting a
tails on the first flip getting a heads
on the second flip and then getting a
tails let me do this in a new color and
then getting a tails on the third flip
so this is going to be equal to the
probability of getting a tails on the
first flip because these are all
independent events having one event if
you know that has it you had a tail on
the first flip that doesn't affect the
probability of getting a heads on the
second flip so times the probability of
getting a heads on the second flip and
then that's times the probability of
getting a tails on the third flip times
the probability of tails on the third
flip and the probability of getting a
tails on any flip we know is 0.4 the
probability of getting a heads on any
flip probability of heads on any flip is
is 0.6 and then the probability of
getting a tails on any flip is 0.4 is
equal to 0.4 and so once again we can
just multiply these so 0.4 times 0.6 so
if we multiply if we multiply 0.4 times
0.6 there's actually a couple of ways we
can think about it well we could
literally say look we're multiplying
four times six times four and then we
have three numbers behind the decimal
point so let's do it that way 4 times 6
is 24 24 24 times 4 is 96 so it gives us
we get 9 we write a 9 6 but remember we
have three numbers behind the decimal
point so it's one one behind to the
right of the decimal there one to the
right of decimal there so three to the
right so we need three to the right of
the decimal in our answer so one two we
need one more to the right of the
decimal so our answer is zero point zero
nine six or another way to think about
it is write an equal sign here this is
equal to a nine point six percent chance
so there's a little bit less than a 10
percent chance or a little bit less than
one in ten chance of when we flip this
coin three times us getting exactly a
tails on the first flip a heads on the
second flip
and a tails on the third flip